notre garçon qui voulait être avec nous
ce soir si c'est franck dubosc franck
dubosc le 27 novembre
il a décidé d'apporter son soutien au
gilet jaune sur facebook avec un message
regardez le message qu'il avait lancée
puis ans est parti juste un message qui
s'adresse bien sûr gilet jaune mais
aussi à tous ceux qui souffrent moi je
fais partie des privilégiés
j'ai cette énorme source c'est vrai mais
je sais d'où je viens je sais ce que
vous levez gelé compris je le comprends
je suis en ce moment
spectateurs c'est à mon tour d'être
spectateur de 2,2 de ce mal être alors
il faut faire quelque chose je vous
comprends on va faire quelque chose quoi
faire quelque chose c'est promis donc il
a des mines message au gilet jaune et à
vous tous qui souffrait il faut que l'on
soit avec vous nous les favoriser il
faut qu'on trouve quelque chose j'en
parle aux copains dès la publication de
cette vidéo
franck dubosc a reçu plein d' insulte
soutien moncube il ne le dit jamais il a
l'air gêné plus tôt
regardez bien écoutez bien la gerbe au
oui franck tu reviens d'un camping de
deux semaines au groenland tu découvres
le combat des gilet jaune
aurais tu peur de perdre des auditeurs
on ne ne soutenant pas bouffon faux cul
tu fais en sorte qu'on sache pas si tu
soutiens des filets jaunes ou si tu
diffuse un message d'intox du
gouvernement si c'est pour dire ça c'est
pas la peine
ce que tu dois dire c'est que les gens
en ont marre de se faire pisser dessus
et que ça doit changer et on a eu plein
n'importe quoi encore plus con que ce
que je pensais
on connaissait franck dubosc artistes
beauf est médiocre par excellence on
découvrait consternation le démago
populiste et pire l'hypocrite qui
sauvent sur les gilet jaune pour vendre
sa propre soupe
tu aurais dû fermer ta gueule tout court
à leur espèce de couillon en slip c'est
bien content que les jd josserand ps ton
compte en banque
aller voir des films et des spectacles
et ben voilà qu'est ce que vous dites ça
ça juste moi j'aimerais parce qu'il va
être avec nous rendre dans un instant
qu'est ce que vous dites à ça à ses
tweets juste après ça parce que
l'ignorance c'est pas possible ça allait
mais noble ou vil c'est minable
partout je n'étais pas au courant
minorité chez les jeunes et jaune une
minorité g
vounet minorité par tout je sais d
odieux c'est au titan marquée qu'attendu
rendez compte qu'il a pris là j'en ai lu
que c'est fait dc c'est pas le dirigeant
ne s'adresse que les personnes qui à
part qu'il a remis à présent en tant que
ça non plus si c'est moi c'est toujours
ça qu'il faut voir
non mais c'est pas il nous représente
pas ces gens là lors mois franck dubosc
jean qui rit c'est la france pardon
depuis quand twitter c'est la france qui
va être avec nous de la caisse qu'il est
venu sur un rond-point ou venir nous
voir en nous on l'aurait appris la
connaît alors je sais alors je vous le
dit ensuite froch
il est parti en tunisie ne le dirons
signer des autographes
franck est un fan lui a demandé s'il
accepté d'être le parrain d'une émission
consacrée au gilet jaune oui c'était
après avoir pris toutes ces insultes
giuly la celi la odieux pour n'y a pas
l'habitude et il s'est senti je pense
très très mal il va nous ont parlé d'un
instant on va regarder la vidéo
et puis les traditionnelles agapes
derrière on dit est ce que tu peux voir
si la personne un gilet jaune ou pas
vraies bases et jaar mais c'est vrai ce
que je veux dire oui mais je comprends
je comprends il n'y a pas de souci s'est
fait défoncer mais non mais je comprends
mais ça ne représente pas c'est un mais
c'est ainsi en tant que gilet jaune en
date c'est comme dans les médias où on
te dit les casseurs sont des jaunes
c'est faux et archi faux
la haine s'exprime beaucoup plus
facilement les aspects la cocarde en
vidéo on aurait déjà quitté le gêner
c'est à la sortie d'un spectacle regarde
consacré au gilet jaune sûrement pas
dans les jt
c'est passé monsieur hirsch aux haineux
3 dégagé c'est vrai c'est fini parce que
vous avez peur de ce qui va se passer
samedi puis j'ai peur de ce que je suis
comme tous les français et donc il
n'avait pas un bon fond à vouloir faire
ce qu'ils voulaient faire non graisseuse
avait dit alors franck dubosc est avec
nous je voudrais comme d'applaudir parce
qu'il a le courage de venir ce soir en
face à l'egypte joue dans face de vous
voilà franck dubosc et avec nos
applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
hier
[Musique]
alors toi alors que le froc
c'est très intéressant de vous écouter
je me perds 2 bravo pour ce que vous
avez eue et la suite rond en parler est
ce que tu me posais une question avant
où tu veux que je n'en veux juste moi ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que je vous
jure
et je vous le parle sincèrement franck
tout le week end il était dévastée par
ce qui s'est passé et par cette vidéo
combien de mois vraiment je le sais je
le connais je sais qu'il était sincère
et ça lui a fait tellement de mal de
parler comme ça de vous de 2,2 pour de
voir cette ville de journée je n'ai pas
parlé de vous comme ça là je vous avoue
effectivement c'est vrai qu'on voit pas
le gilet jaune sur le est-ce que vous
pouvez imaginer quand je doute moi je ne
fais pas de politique je parle jamais de
politique
enfin que vous m'aimiez ou pas vous le
savez que je m'investis pas dans la
politique je suis un clown
ouais et puis et puis je vois ma maman
j'en ai entendu certain temps dans
certains d'entre-vous pardon je
bredouille parce que je suis ému gagnent
moins que certains d'entre vous elle a
une chance c'est d'avoir un fils qui est
un hyper privilégié je vous la vous je
suis désolé si fournée de désolé alors
voilà très bien travaillé là elle a
cette chance d'avoir son fiston et nous
regarde là elle nous regarde
elle vous entend elle doit se dire mais
mon pauvre fille ce que fais tu quand
j'ai soutenu quand j'ai fait la première
vidéo
j'étais même ému quand je les fait je
les fait tout seul dans ma chambre
tournée je me suis dit c'est pas
possible j'ai juste après appelé cyril
je ne sais pas possible faut faire
quelque chose dit à ma mère et à ma
soeur qui a tous les gens que je vois et
mon public il ya tout ça j'ai besoin
j'ai besoin de tous ces gens moi aussi
si je veux être égoïste et et puis je
sais d'où je viens excusez moi mais je
sais d'où je viens je suis qui je suis
même si je suis très privilégiée c'est
vrai et puis j'ai reçu ces messages de
haine c'était sûrement pas bien entendu
c'était pas de gilet jaune ou des jeux
les jaunes aussi un j'en sais rien
on espérait honnêtement je me suis
trouvé à faiblir je me suis trouvée
affaiblie
j'ai pas l'habitude mois de ça j'ai pas
le bien c'est moi je suis juste un prime
on me dit je t'aime bien tu me fais rire
ou tu me fait pas rire et du coup je me
suis mais qu'est ce que j'ai fait
pourquoi pourquoi je fais ça on s'est eu
je suis dans la banque du coeur on a
parlé
les données je suis le premier je dis
bien sûr j'ai appelé ma femme bien
évidemment bien évidemment et puis et
puis tout à coup je suis affaibli je
vous la vouge eux avec tous ces messages
je suis pas l'habitude et e
et puis je vois la violence à la
télévision c'est parce qu'à part que moi
le nez le débat qui ne sont pas vous
aussi je le sais je croisais beaucoup
d'entre vous après qui en a parlé et et
puis aussi je le vois bien enfin je
parle idiot mais je les prie pour moi
bêtement
voilà et puis arrivé au bout d'une
semaine je suis en suisse
affaibli je lui sors de ce spectacle je
suis fatigué mais ça j'ai fait mon
travail c'est tout j'ai signé des
autographes je sors et est ce monsieur
qui vient à un moment il faut pas venir
je suis énervé je suis excédé d'ailleurs
je dis là est né là vous voyez je ne
parle pas du combat je ne parle pas du
centre du combat et je craque je craque
parce que je suis un être humain et et
que et voilà maintenant je vais vous
dire une chose
la première vidéo là je pourrais leur
poste alors j'ai effacé à un moment je
joue là oui j'ai effacé les vidéos que
j'avais mise à première vidéo je ne
contrôle pas bien tout ça je suis tout
seul sur mon facebook c'est moi qui
réponds à mes messages c'est moi qui les
messages je suis tout seul j'ai pas de
webmasters temps mais dit il je l'effacé
au sujet fasse et je ne savais pas
comment faire
et puis alors là ce a redoublé et je
comprends que c'est redoublé 1 et ce
monsieur quand il est arrivé près de moi
j'étais mal à l'aise j'étais je les ai
vus fils mais est-ce que ça son truc n'a
pas été on n'a pas effacé j'ai des gens
autour de moi n'a pas effacé
parce que il a le droit il me pose une
question est alors la question est pas
exactement au début il voulait faire une
émission de télé ou les cadreurs
seraient des gilets jaunes
je suis désolé je vous le dis mais c'est
comme ça mais c'est pas pour ça que j'ai
répondu ça bien évidemment maintenant je
reste sur mes convictions parce que le
combat c'est vous c'est avec vous pour
être ou contre vous moi je reste je ne
revient pas en arrière j'ai fait j'ai
fait une énorme erreur
c'est l'erreur d'un homme lpr maintenant
je suis là moi aussi vous parler de 20%
vous parlez de 20%
un tire lait de 20% d'isoler vous voulez
merci alors voilà mais oui est ce que
vous croyez
est ce que vous croyez franchement pour
moi un porte parole je n'ai pas les
épaules je vous desservirait en soutien
comme on peut le faire nous ça
volontiers volontiers vous parlez de 80%
pour 7 20% en 50 40
moi je peut vous amener peut-être 500
plus j'en sais rien je ne sais quoi
c'est avec mes petits bras d'acteur mais
petit bras clown je ne suis pas le débat
est tout à coup ça s'est enflammé franck
dubosc le clown en maillot de bain de
camping tout à coup et haï parce qu'il a
juste dit ça mais retombe ait ailleurs
il me semble t'il
le combat est ailleurs ma mère quand
elle a vu ça l'a dit mon pauvre franck
mais mon père est mort au chômage
mon mât mais je n'ai même pas besoin de
servir de ses pendants et c'est parce
que tu es en touche il est que tu crois
que m et un doublé décédé merci alors je
vais parler d'eux s'est même pas besoin
de parler de le faire maintenant
maintenant vous me mettez ça pour dire
que je vais vous dire une autre chez le
citoyen lui mais je suis citoyen et plus
je suis si je vis dans la même france
que vous avec une énorme chance des
randonnées vous rappelez vous tous à
plusieurs niveaux la chance que vous
avez déjà de monter oui je ne suis là
c'est fait que vous montez avec autant
de gros salaires je ne sais pas ce
système qui veut ça
mais rappelez-vous de kilamba non
scellées place mais on le sait le cec
vous savez on le sert ga
il faut la seule année je le redis
encore si on va faire et j'ai juste vu
couper parce que vous trouvez que je
rebondis sur ce que vous venez de dire
est que souvenez vous des quais alors ce
que tout ce que je peux dire avec vous
oui cette différence ouais vous ne
supplanterait jamais la différence que
j'ai eu avec mon père parce que mon père
c'est l'homme que j'aimais le plus au
monde
comprenez oui et cette différence quand
elle est arrivée sur le sur l'argent sur
ce que je devenais on n'a pas supporté
et lui et moi il est mort sans que je
puisse lui dire je t'aime alors aucun
personnes
aucun être humain ne pourra me dire tu
es différent j'étais différent
précédent qui grand malheur avec le
peuple français ce différent cela je la
connais c'est ce que je suis en train de
jouer dans la misère c'est ce que je
suis il ya une chose que je voulais dire
moi je comprends en fait ce que vous
êtes en train de dire vous avez lu tout
ce qui n'allait pas enfin les insultes
les injures etc
en fait nous quand on a entendu votre
deuxième vidéo nous avons eu exactement
les mêmes sentiers le comprend et du
coup ce qui vous appréciez je le
confesse être jeu le combat du coup on a
eu cette haine qui venu d'un coup delic
je le comprends je comprends et moi et
là je me justifie la cour et leur taux
de mentions bien évidemment mais je
voulais et c'est pour ça que ce soit
c'est pour ça pour ça que ce soir je
remercie cyril de venir au moins vous
l'expliquez vous l'entendez comme vous
l'entendez au moins vous l'expliquer oui
c'est un ce n'est pas un retournement
cwid sur le moment oui ça qu'on l'a
c'est un choc que j'ai eus je n'étais
pas habitué oui mais hélas si ça peut
servir à quelque chose c'est de dire à
tous les autres tout ce je ne suis pas
le seul j'ai parlé à mes collègues m'ont
dit tous ceux qui ont pris la main
souvent on était aussi insulté et on en
a parlé on a dit mais c'est pas eux vont
courtiser c'est pas vous c'est pas vous
c'est les autres ah bon et on en a parlé
si ça peut servir aux gens qui veulent
excusez moi je qui veulent vous aider de
leur montrer que les violences dans la
rue que les violences verbales sur
internet ce n'est par jour et ben moi ça
va servir la sphère mode
moi je voulais vous demander vous savez
comme un fait une troisième cas cette
vidéo vous était en train de nous
narguer genre faites ce que vous voulez
j'aurais quand même les salles complètes
ou l'avait fait le premier sas on
réponse du coup nos mémoires c'était
après l'ewi alors c'est pas lui passons
non non non non alors là on m'a dit que
ma mère meurt l'instant
j'ai fait jamais de la vie là j'ai pensé
alors là excusez moi le débat est clos
non mais ces gens pour faire c'est l'âme
de la jambe et son attentat syrie si
j'ai dit ça je vous demande de me lire
jusqu'à la fin j'avais tout genre n'ont
toujours pas c'est horrible non mais
c'est pas mal cette femme est choisi je
le regarde et vous dites que les gens
qui 8 vous dit que les gens qui
balancent et insultes cette immonde ce
que vous n'êtes c'est une on vous dit
qu'on arrivait à regarder une vidéo dans
le palais non c'est moi vous me
reconnaissez au couple ahonado sur un
faux débat
c'est ce que je vais penser c'est que
hervé matin ce que tu comprends pas mais
oui parce que je n'avais je ne savais
pas qu'il avait reçu autant de tweets
ravala de ce genre donc c'est vrai qu'on
n'a pas compris ce retournement et je
joue maintenant c'est bien d'ailleurs de
t'expliquer devant nous et pour ma part
oui j'apprécie et je remercie mon
collègue du temps mis sa mère d'avoir
donné le savoir ce que oui tu le mets
alors il le fait que tu sois là devant
nous excuser t'es pas obligé de sévir
pour ces iem évidemment j'avais envie de
tarifs qu'elle envoyait hume a dû faire
camping 3 et puis c'est ok là on voit un
homme en bois un homme qui est qui qui a
été qui a été frappé par un par une
forme d'émotion une forme de stupeur de
voir qu'il a été insulté alors utile
d'oubli pas d'où il vient
il a réussi il a fait passer un premier
message qui était très positif le combat
de la justice sociale il faut pas qu'ils
versé vers le combat de la jalousie de
ceux qui ont réussi les actes sinon on
va passer entre les amis moi jouer je
dis seulement que quelques mais nos
milieux populaires comme lui ou comme
cyril ou comme d'autres et qui réussit
mais j'admire dès demain le problème de
notre cité on peut le regretter c'est
que dans certaines corporations
effectivement les jeunes je suis mieux
populaire ne montrent pas assez vite il
ya ce qu'on appelle un plafond de verre
dans le monde artistique
il arrive encore à réussir le combat
qu'on a mené tous ces qui plus de mai
c'est une issue de milieux populaires
qui est que c'est pas l'énarchie qui
dirige le pays
le problème aujourd'hui on sait qu'on a
un système fait d'énarques deux filles
ne détienne est certaine pour le co
fondée par mathieu deux ans de cela
c'est pas les jeunes lemieux populaire
on parle bien de l'ena l'école nationale
des abrutis évidemment si jean-claude
joe cole alors j'aurai juste dire à
dernis mais qu'est ce que j'aime mon
boulot je vous laisse élévateur leur
contenu mais j'aurais juste dire une
dernière chose dont franck tu sais que
tu sais que je t'aime très fort on est
on est vraiment potes dans la vie et moi
je vous dire exactement s'est passé
c'est que le lendemain quand il a vu les
gilet jaune chez nous le premier jour il
m'a appelé et il m'a dit cyril qu'elle
succombe faire parce que moi je peux pas
rester comme ça et j'ai envie de faire
quelque chose pour eux moi je préfère un
mec comme ça ils disent syrie qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
parce qu'il n'a pas besoin froch il
aurait pu rester trop qui ne rien faire
je moi je voulais faire un mec comme lui
suis désolé qu'ils se mouiller
parce que je vous le dis moi y'en a
plein voilà qui gît pas voilà mais c'est
vrai qu'un à plein ils font ce qu'ils
veulent bien à plailly six mois je veux
pas d'histoires
je continue mon petit boulot tout marche
bien pour braga
je veux pas être sali je veux pas moi
dieu ou lycées combats de chiens j'ai
endommagé deux mecs je vous dis donc il
me dit à chaque fois je leur dis chez
les jaunes ah non moi je veux pas gilet
jaune passagers feront le droit de le
penser mais bien sûr quand généraux il a
voulu aider les jours et il s'en est
pris plein la gueule
donc ça je vous dis alors si vous êtes
habitués depuis des années n'a vous en
prendre plein la figure et ben ouais ça
chez moi ça on a parlé avec lui m'a dit
moi j'ai l'habitude
moi j'ai l'habitude non il ya des gens
qui m'aiment et n'a pas l'habitude et
les gens qui m'aiment pas ils s'en
foutent de moi ils vont pas ça non pas
écrire alors que j'étais non plein de
gens qui m'aiment pas ya plus de gens
qui m'aiment pas là ce que du
relationnel et une déversoir de verre
alors jusqu'où je suis jeune je maîtrise
je vous dis je c'est vrai on va là il ya
une truite est correct voilà merci je
voudrais quand même préciser que j'en ai
eu quand même des bons merci on a eu des
chantiers
merci de prendre du box d'avoir été avec
nous